When we use the quadratic formula, we want to be sure to use parenthesis. We
want to use parenthesis around the values of b, a, and c. For this equation,
the value of a is 3, the value of b is negative 4, and the value of c is
negative 5. So these are the placeholders for the numbers a, b, and c. You
should always do this when you start to solve a quadratic equation using the
quadratic formula. This will prevent us from making any sign mistakes with
negative b and the minus 4ac. So we plug in the value of b here and here, the
value of a here and here, and the value of c here. Now that we've plugged in,
it's time to simplify. You try simplifying this expression, and when you think
you have your final answer, enter it here. You can either write your answer as
two fractions with plus or minus in between them or you can enter in your
answer as one giant fraction. The plus or minus symbol will be in the
numerator.